merry almost christmas
uh happy
holidays
whatever you celebrate
uh i hope you got a little bit of joy in
you that's oh holy night right there
and they i think they're talking about
the night
of our dear savior's birth that's what
they're going into there you know and i
think that's just that night where
you know that baby shows up
where that baby
shows up and that baby they're talking
about the dang lord
you know
they're talking about that mulligan
you know they're talking about
humanity's mulligan
when god was like dang
this ain't going so hot
i'm gonna have i'm gonna send somebody a
trooper i'ma send my little super
trooper down there to shake it up
or shake it up
and that's when we got the lord
and he showed up as a baby
you know
the lord showed up as a dang
baby
and people don't think about that
sometimes
you know because if i should like if i
if i go into battle if i'm going out
there to get things done
if i you know what i'm saying heck if i
even go outside and it's raining i need
an umbrella if i even you know if i if
it's going to be dusty i need to
you know um
have special goggles
you know if i'm going you know if i'm
going into a scary area i might take a
bow and arrow or take a little hatchet
but to think that the lord
showed up out here
he showed up out here as a baby to do
battle
and that's
that's sneaky and that's beautiful
and that's one thing that i think
sometimes about you know when you get
into these stories of
um
into these religious tales
you know and you hear you hear them and
you and
you know it they're all kind of like uh
they're all
you know
fables if you will
um and i'm not saying that you know i'm
not i'm not commenting on religion here
they're all stories that's what i'm
saying they're all stories they're all
histories
um that are meant to teach us something
you know no matter what book you're
reading the story in
or no book at all
but i i do believe you're out there
running freelance without any higher
power in your life good luck out there
okay because you're trying to work an
iphone without a charger cable as far as
i'm concerned
but it is interesting when you think
about that the lord showed up as a dang
baby to do battle
dude
that's the last thing i would do
it just doesn't seem it's you know well
first of all nobody expects it so it's
crafty that's crafty
but you're just so you don't have any
real i mean your special skills
are crying
you know cuteness
you know um
you know uh
making noises cute noises that's like
your basically your superpowers cute
noises
and burping
i mean that was the lord's superpowers
when he showed up as a baby
you know and that's just brave i think i
think it's brave to show up and do
battle
to take
the take away the sins of the wild
as a dang baby
you know spider-man was peter parker
you know clark kent you know at least
superman his he started off he worked at
a newspaper
but the lao
showed up and said you know what
send me in as a baby and i'm still gonna
get the job done so i got to say world's
most successful baby
or entrepreneur as a human the lord
and it's that time of year man and
that's what they're talking about that
oh holy night and it's just about you
know how you show up
and to show up as a baby and to toe the
line
i think you know that's pretty cool and
it's a powerful story
you know and also to be born out there
in the desert man
i mean that's crazy
i mean i know good and well
have you seen a baby out in arizona dude
you go out there to uh out towards
bisbee arizona out there towards outside
of glendale where it hits 130.
do you see a baby out there look like a
damn lizard
i mean they got babies out there weigh
four or five pounds and they're probably
about nine months old
you know you got a lot of babies they
look like smokers they've been smoking
cigarettes
and they're you know scaly
you know what i'm saying you got
you got a little bit of you know
they're ba you know they're they got it
they got that lizard in them they got
long tongues i mean it's
it's hard to be a baby in a desert
because you need milk they barely have
anything you can even get milk out of in
a desert
be that babe show up and be that wild
baby
i mean
you know what i'm saying
uh jesus christmas was a beautiful baby
i mean that baby showed up in the desert
had a couple of old dudes walked out to
the middle of the desert to meet a baby
now
100 illegal to do that
100 illegal in fact it's a tv show now
hell if you're an old man even going to
meet a 14 year old for some lemonade or
whatever they bust you
so the fact that three old men were
cruising out into the desert to meet a
child
that is
that's a that's a crime now
that's wild to think that what was a
rich what was what what is the story of
one of the most popular religions is now
a crime
and they got sheep there and animals you
can't have children around livestock i
know there's some you know in some
states there's some legal issues about
that if you're trying to transport them
across state lines and stuff so
who knows
but i think if the if the lord ever come
back it's going to be through an alien
or
how else could he come back maybe portal
wishing well
i don't know he could fly of elon musk's
nut sack i bet who knows how he could
come back but it's nice to think it's
exciting
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you